and allah knows but allah calls him both
back
he says you when he was going why was
you going so sloppy and looking back he
said oh allah i knew you to be the man
and and i was looking for your mercy
said okay he said to the second one i
said to you go hellfire why did you run
he said oh allah i never obeyed you on
earth
you asked me to do one thing once i said
let me do it without questioning
allah said both you enter paradise
the
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah's book like you've never had
before okay salaam alaikum guys hope you
guys everything inshallah so we're here
at salaam corner we have a sister and
sister you're right
what's your name
is that turkish because i'm kurdish from
turkey
okay
and so basically you had a question
regarding was it good um
you you tell me so
why would god punish
um if god is good
okay like not the punishment of you know
like promising punishment i'll punish
you if you do this i understand that it
deters yeah but
why would god
bills do with that when life is
overgrown there's no creativity from the
punishment okay so so is your question
for example when the person dies
or
or the creation comes to an end why does
the punishment continue
yes okay so i understand in this life
you might be punished but now that you
can't hurt anyone like you can't do the
same thing again yeah why would you then
be punished okay so you know for example
the way we can answer this is firstly we
need to understand who was allah's
attributes here so you said you define
yourself as a muslim that you have a
doubt yeah okay doubts are normal look
we all have doubts yeah sometimes i i
have certain questions i'm like okay
that doesn't make sense to me it doesn't
make me a disbeliever it's just i'm
learning so you're a muslim that's good
that you know yourself as a muslim and
hold on to the identity you know it's
normal you have doubt you ask questions
i i ask
one of the reasons i came to islam is
because of that there was question that
i wanted to know so when we refer to
allah we need to understand he's not
just merciful and all good he's the just
he's the most wise so those attributes
work together you know it's not just one
okay it's just wise that's it no it's
also the most just
so
when a crime is committed we tend to
look at the who it's committed against
a crime that's committed if i go and or
if somebody comes and kills a man
the punishment for that and that person
killing a woman or that person killing a
child or that person killing their baby
is different
right because the crime
is different
and also it goes with people of social
stature so for example the queen
if somebody goes and kills the queen
or the prime minister it's not the same
as killing your foe even though in the
sight of god almighty they're both human
beings
but the crime varies so if somebody it
took someone
20 seconds to kill somebody
why are they going to end up in prison
for 20 years the crime will took only 20
seconds because to deter other people
okay number one number one to deter
number two you've taken somebody's life
so even though the action may have been
20 seconds to kill
but the consequences of that and taking
that person from their loved ones
it's it can be in some states that like
they have capital punishment
so it depends who the crime is done
against how severe it is
now we believe the worst thing in
this world to commit his shirk do you
know what shirk is to associate partners
to allah now we can't fathom and
understand that because we do not fully
most of the times it comes from the lack
of um knowing who allah is and knowing
what he does once we acknowledge and we
fully can't who he is and what he does
and how magnificent he is we will truly
understand how evil shirk is
so for example you have a mom and dad
right
so your mum and dad and i give this
example a lot because it relates more
you know
your mom looks after you brings you to
this age
imagine you go to your mom and you slap
her
and you say i'm gonna go and thank ali
how what kind of how severe would you
say that is what you've done there
that's very bad very bad what if you
can
become what about sister became what if
you are a very charitable person sister
became gives charity to everybody
are you a good person
i don't know
if you beat your mama but you give help
everyone are you good or bad
i mean like if you do both
you're doing both
i don't know but i would say i would
necessarily say if somebody is evil to
their mom i don't care if they're good
to the whole world because
the the evil that you're doing there it
doesn't matter if you're helping the
entire globe you're you're harming your
mother who's giving birth i don't
disagree that i want to punish people i
agree yeah i want people to be punished
okay that sounds good okay
okay
yes
i don't know what's happening in their
life yes
right yes and
allah is more forgiving than me yes so
i can forgive the person who steals my
back yes
okay
once he saw um there was a war that
happened some captives were taken and
there was a woman there the prophet said
you see that woman there and she lost a
child so she's looking for a child said
you see that woman do you think that
woman would put her her child in the
hell fire and the companion said
as far as we know she's in the right
mind she will never follow the child
into the fire he said allah is more
merciful to his servants than that woman
to their child so and we also know from
another hadith that the prophet said
allah is more merciful 99 times 100
times more merciful than a mother to the
child so the default position is what
allah says in the quran what will i get
out of punishing you so allah saying i
don't want to punish you so let's
understand because some people have a
misconception that allah is someone that
wants to throw everyone's hell fire no
the default position is allah wants
jannah for you that's the default
position however when we compare someone
stealing your purse or murdering someone
and you say you'll forgive them and
allah tells you to forgive them allah
says better if you do so in a situation
of murder there's three conditions an
eye for an eye somebody killed your
brother they have the person that then
has to be killed or number two they have
to pay blood money or their family you
can forgive them allah says it's better
if you forgive so here why would allah
contradict himself but if we equate why
would that contradiction because you
know you said if i would forgive
if allah says forgive them but he's not
forgiving those and find them hellfire
forever it seems like it's contradicting
but it's not the point here is this
stealing and murder we're comparing it
with ship and because we don't buy them
[ __ ] we're saying how could it be i'll
forgive someone if someone stole my
purse but why is allah forgiving the
ship it's as good as me equating the
following somebody took one pin one
penny from me and i go i forgive him and
somebody goes somebody's child is
murdered in front of them
and they say i want that person to be
killed and i go why would you do that i
just forgave someone for taking a penny
from me and you don't forgive them for
killing your child it's two different
worlds and the comparison is wrong
trying to say because mine was a penny
insignificant to them their child was
killed in front of them how can i go to
that person and say just forgive them
look i just gave you one p
the comparison there is loads of things
now when it comes to ship sister imagine
murder okay what's the most disgusting
thing that can we say
that can happen imagine very disgusting
imagine a child being raped and killed
and imagine a body dismembered
it can't get worse than that i don't
think it can
that is wrong and allah forbids [ __ ] is
a billion times longer than that
sheikh is one billion times more wrong
than that so therefore when allah
destined certain people to hell fire
forever it's only the people's system
listen carefully the ones who have
disbelieved knowing that islam is the
truth so they know islam is the truth
they know allah shall be worshipped they
reject it because of arrogance
but islam is the only religion that says
sister if you an atheist an agnostic a
hindu or christian or any other religion
if you didn't hear the message of islam
allah will not throw into the hellfire
you have a specific test the prophet
mentioned on the day of judgment because
allah is just how could allah throw
someone in hell fire when he's never
heard about islam so the thing is here
allah is just allah will give you every
opportunity to believe in him but if you
systematically reject that all the time
then how are you how is allah unjust by
following you hellfire forever because
allah says if we send you to the earth
you do the same thing over again so you
know for example with murderers serial
murderers
because government knows or the legal
system knows that person might go out
and kill again they don't give them
parole
because they know we let them out once
he went and killed again
why because they know he's even if he
send back he'll do the same thing again
so because allah knows that
no no allah says in the quran it's very
interesting allah says in the quran if
we was to send the disbelievers who were
they doomed to hell fire if we were to
send them back to earth and they say to
allah give us a chance we'll change
allah says no if we was to send them
back they would do the same thing again
but they're here
like allah will not send them back no no
but no no no but what allah is saying is
if i was to
allah if i did let's suppose allah said
no problem go to earth allah saying that
if you send them to earth for a million
years they'll commit suicide a billion
years they'll commit a billion years the
point allah's trying to make is that
they would never change but because
they're in the fire they're in regret
like if i we catch hitler hello i'm so
sorry
i'm terribly wrong give me another
chance he'll go and do it again so
because allah knows that
he says the punishment for you is
eternal hell fire because if you live
eternally you will commit that crime
eternally
so you only go
you're only sent to hell for sure
look check this out look how mercy look
how much sister
allah saying to you look
there is all kinds of meat that you can
eat stay away from pork
there's all kinds of juice orange juice
apple juice grape juice stay away from
alcohol
you have 24 hours a day pray five
minutes five times a day
you have a whole seven days go juma once
you have a
whole year 11 months past one month
you got your entire life try to go hajj
ones the point i'm trying to say that
allah has given so many options and
allah says the only sin look you're
going to commit murder allah will
forgive you you're going to commit even
ship if you're committing it and repent
allah forgives you only if you die
committed [ __ ] only one sin that allah
will never forgive isn't that merciful
that allah saying you commit so many
sins you are ungrateful and i will
forgive you but only ship i thought it
was like there's like a tally of your
life
yeah and then they're like
the angels are like yeah they're right
yeah you have good and bad days and then
you they balance and it's like oh you're
bad okay no this is how it works check
this out yeah let me tell you something
here this is something we can all learn
together here
we enter paradise okay when allah talks
about hellfire in paradise
when allah talks about hellfire it says
what the disbelievers earned the word is
earned
they earned it when allah talks about
paradise
allah doesn't mention earth
allah talks about in a way where it's
gifted to you
so meaning there is nothing that we can
human beings do
to earn paradise it's by allah's mercy
and how do we know that there's a hadith
of the prophet peace be upon him he says
a man came on the day of judgment a very
righteous man who lived a very long time
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i think he
went somewhere else i'm so sorry about
that i'm going to go in yeah yeah i
haven't got the virus but you know
they're playing you never know a man can
imagine to the prophet and he said oh i
went to
allah he said allah i want to enter
paradise
by my good deeds
allah said okay let's get this you know
the mizan um
so she's talking
first time i'm speaking to the turkish
sister okay so he put all his goodies on
one side
and he took his eye
and puts it on the other side you're
interested the angel said yeah
the i wait all the good things are done
meaning
the blessing of the i you can never
repay with all your goodies that you did
for 100 years that's the point so allah
said to the man
based on my justice go to hellfire
because what did he say he said allah i
want to enter paradise
with my good deeds allah is showing here
your good deeds mean nothing in the
sight of the blessing of your eye
so allah said go to hell fire he said oh
allah please let me enter paradise by
your mercy
so the lesson we learn from the sister
is that we
in reality we do good this because of
what allah is but eventually our
destination to paradise is by allah's
mercy not our good deeds the good is we
do it regardless because you are how
great allah is so
there's another hadith when you said for
example there might be some people on
the day of judgement their baddies
outweigh their good deeds
but allah might forgive them how because
there is a hadith of
two people
and allah says to both of them
call hellfire
one of them runs the hellfire literally
runs the other one
walks in disappointment
and allah knows but allah calls him both
back
he says you when he was going why was
you going so sloppy and looking back he
said oh allah i knew you to be the man
and
and i was looking for your mercy
said okay he said to the second one i
said to you go hell fire why did you run
he said oh allah i never obeyed you on
earth
you asked me to do one thing once i said
let me do it without questioning allah
said both of you enter paradise
the point here is this is stuck no it's
amazing because people make it seem as
if allah is like a monster he's looking
to put people in hell fire allah doesn't
want fire for you and that's why allah
will be angry on the day of judgment
that the disbelievers chose hellfire
over jannah
it passes your question
and also if i may add like the people
who are usually described going to
are despicable yes they're arrogant
they're oppressive and they're very
violent and they're very like they mock
people yeah very little people they
don't give and they're stingy yeah allah
says that